nos dicen la pastelería de betty calcula
el precio total de en pesos por cada c
pastelitos usando la ecuación de igual a
2 x c que significa el 2 en esta
situación pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar la respuesta correcta antes de
ver las respuestas vamos a comprender
qué es lo que nos dicen en el enunciado
la ecuación es igual a 2 x c esto quiere
decir que la cantidad de pastelitos que
alguien compra se multiplica por 2 para
calcular la cantidad de pesos del precio
así que este 2 quiere decir que cada
pastelito cuesta 2 pesos porque
cualquiera que sea la cantidad de
pastelitos que se compren se tiene que
multiplicar por 2 pesos para calcular el
precio la opción dice que la pastelería
cobra 2 pesos por cada pastelito que
coincide justamente con lo que acabamos
de analizar la opción b dice que la
pastelería vende 2 pastelitos por cada
peso
y esto no es lo que ocurre vamos a
probarlo digamos que compramos un
pastelito así que se es igual a 1 a que
es igual de vamos a hacer una tabla
cuando se es igual a 1 d es igual a 2
cuando sea es igual a 2 lo multiplicamos
por 2 y es igual a 4 lo que coincide con
la opción a pero no con la opción b pues
dos pastelitos no cuestan dos pesos sino
cuatro pesos la opción se dice que la
pastelería vende dos tipos de pastelitos
y en el enunciado no dicen nada de tipos
diferentes de pastelitos así que también
descartamos la opción c veamos otro
ejercicio elige la tienda que vende la
bola de helado más barata pausa en el
vídeo y traten de encontrar la respuesta
correcta resolvamos estos juntos la
opción a dice la tienda a calcular el
precio total de de helado en pesos por s
bolas usando la ecuación de igual a 0.75
por s cualquiera que sea el valor de
bolas s se multiplica por 0.75 lo que
quiere decir que la cantidad de bolas se
multiplica por 75 centavos o 75
centésimas
de peso para encontrar el precio sabemos
que en la tienda a cada bola cuesta 75
centavos de peso para poder comparar el
precio tenemos que ver cuánto cuestan
las bolas de helado en la tienda ve y en
la tienda se en la tienda ve tres bolas
cuestan tres pesos si se multiplica tres
por uno de tres para ocho bolas las
multiplicamos por uno para tener el
precio de ocho pesos y doce bolas las
precio de 12 pesos así que la ecuación
que usa la tienda ve es que los pesos de
serán igual a 1 por el número de bolas
ese o podemos ver esto como que cada
bola cuesta un peso cuesta un peso cada
bola con esto ya sabemos que la tienda
ve es más cara que la tienda a en la
opción se la relación se describe con
una gráfica pero podemos expresarla como
en las opciones anteriores vamos a hacer
una tabla aquí tenemos las bolas y los
pesos veamos cuando elegimos dos bolas
el precio es de tres pesos aquí elijo
los valores que son sencillos de
encontrar en la gráfica cuatro bolas
cuestan seis pesos lo anotamos en la
tabla con estos datos nos damos cuenta
de que cada
se multiplica por 1.5 para calcular el
precio en pesos la fórmula es que el
precio de es igual a 1.5 por bo la otra
forma de ver esto es que con 1.5 pesos
se compra una bola de helado la tienda
se es la más cara de todas
le sigue la tienda ve y la más barata es
la tienda que es lo que nos preguntan
esta es la opción correcta con esto
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo